bonjour à tous bonjour mon imac nick bel
bonjour madame beau le monde est touché
par le coup vite 19 et la martinique
notre martinique n'y échappe il nous
faut absolument lutter contre
l'évolution de ce virus
en martinique il n'ya qu'une seule
solution pour l'instant si de rester
chez mon mail à magalas d'algérie ni
monde cap et de la vie et chaque les
bouquets payants thann
c'est qu'ils en fassent en mode baby
permettez moi en ma qualité de président
la fédération des yoles rondes de
martinique d'envoyer un message à la
famille de la llo président patron
ochier supporters et type gestion
conseil d'admistration protéger cause
autre protégé forme biseautée protéger
tous à pied entre autres nous kenny
t'envoyer voit le monde et nos élites
ont fait course en tête tout l'art est
un beau bébé
en tout cas pour tout le monde un seul
mot d'ordre resté chiffres